yes
for typos [ __ ] was called Pascoe why he
kept winter 48 yet Otaki father kid
so why my career industry is a great
place to live work and play and this has
not gone unnoticed our population in
business sectors have been growing
rapidly about 50,000 people's currently
called the Y market any district yes and
by 2048 our population maybe close to
100,000 people we are now planning on
how best manage that growth of the next
season here
we will people live work and play do we
have enough length of business and
housing and what should happen in our
rural areas how will our infrastructure
meet this increasing money and how to
replace got a natural environment the
district development strategy will guide
long term growth in our district and
provide the direction with the more
detailed council document such as the
upcoming districts and review it covered
seven main themes which we'll be taking
a closer look at in later videos we'd
like your feedback on this draft
strategy before it's finalized later
this year you can view the document at
any council service center although that
Waimakariri
by govt p stop embed quad / district
development
you